maybe with making a heading above this
somewhere which is to call this
empirical data on the normal
distribution let me write that for you
actually
empirical as in Empire I'll come to that
in a second empirical data on the normal
distribution empirical data just means
we're looking at numbers right there's
no algebra in this question except for
the algebra that we introduced which I'm
about to do shortly okay we're dealing
just with the numbers and so there's a
lot of reading interpretation thinking
about what does this number signify and
then how do I use it what do I do with
it
okay so let's just start reading through
the question and then start to note down
the things that matter and I'm not gonna
write it in a long wordy way I'm gonna
write it in a succinct mathematicians
way
so we're thinking about this Steve's in
it as a Steve Steve the marathon runner
right so he has these times for how
quickly you can run a marathon and we're
gonna jot some of them down right before
we get to his times I believe they say
the mean time in Sidney is 2 hours 15
minutes so which letter which Greek
letter do we usually use for mean mu
very good so I'm gonna write down mu
equals now I could just write down the
time as its given 2 hours 15 minutes but
some of you have noticed later on it
just starts talking in minutes minutes
minutes so let's do a conversion quickly
here 2 hours is a hundred and 20 minutes
so that makes two hours and 15 minutes
135 so I'm going to call this 135
minutes there's the mean and then the
next thing they tell us what's the next
number that they give to us standard
deviation what Greek letter do we
usually use for standard deviation
yeah the Sigma okay very good Sigma
equals what is it to 4.5 sorry 4.5 ah I
can't know we're coming to that right so
that's all the stuff on Sydney right now
then he starts talking about Athens so I
like to make sure when I'm doing the
stage that I don't miss anything so I'm
just going to go from start to finish in
the question and then try and conclude
what do I do with this right so now he
starts talking about a whole different
city Athens right again I get a mean so
he comes mu it's what is it to our 17 so
137 cool hundred thirty-seven minutes I
know what units I me that's a long
marathon if and then standard deviation
for this guy is theory okay is this so
far so good I haven't written down
anything crazy just trying to interpret
question okay so then we have a look at
Steve himself Oh what did I write the
wrong time
136 one mo are so I'm just reading the
next line I'm reading his time
136 all right so alright stay with me
so now that was seamless right so now I
then have to say what about Steve
himself now I've got mean I've got
standard deviation when I have a look at
his time that's what we signify by X
right X is like your particular score so
what is his Sydney running time 137
you'll notice by the way I'm putting the
unit's every single time you might get a
bit sick of that but for me like every
question is going to deal with different
units so I'm kind of scared of getting
units wrong okay Steve's time yep 137
for Sydney and then 139 for Athens okay
now he does why he's a marathon runner
right so we have all of the pieces that
we need to get a dead score out of this
okay and you'll notice by the way I've
set this up so I don't confuse one mu
with another one Sigma with another so
I'm going to go Z equals just this first
time just to make sure I get around and
just write the formula it's a fraction
right what's on the numerator X minus mu
very good so it's the difference between
your score or his score in the mean and
then we divide by standard deviation
Sigma okay let's go ahead and just
crunch the numbers so a hundred and
thirty seven gonna make sure I know
which ones which right take away 135 all
divided by 4.5 yes 0.4
for whether a figure on the top four
four four that's four over nine isn't it
okay so that's good let's rehearse that
same process for Athens I'm just gonna
go straight to putting the numbers in
cuz I already have a four-minute 139
make sure I get the right one takeaway
136 on three even I can tell that's just
one okay so I've got my z-scores now and
then here's the critical bit right what
matters that statistics is what can you
say from this what is the interpretation
which was the better performance
zette score of no point four four four
four four Zed score of one now we
instinctively say Oh higher scores
better except hold on a second these are
times right these are times to be faster
is better to be smaller is better so
actually the lower the z score the lower
the Zed score the better it is okay so
what I would say is which was the better
performance number one I would say
Sydney is the better performance okay
the reasoning is that his Zed score for
Sydney is lower and because x we want
lower is better a lower Zed score like
if he had his head scores like negative
two right it's like well you're way down
that end you've got a much smaller time
than everyone else which is fast that
makes sense okay so you can see how it's
not just about the number crunching it's
about how you interpret it